when George Lucas came up with the idea
of Star Wars in the mid-1970s setting an
adventure of this scope and outerspace
had never been done before so how did he
get the film to look so good when there
were no visual effects companies up to
the challenge at the time he started his
own Industrial Light & Magic was formed
to handle the special effects in Star
Wars and they're still revolutionising
the industry with their work let's peek
behind the scenes at what Star Wars
movies look like before they work their
magic a new hope the original trilogy is
known for its use of practical effects
but in truth those films relied on
visual trickery just as much as their
successors sprawling CGI backgrounds
were not an option when the first Star
Wars movie was being made so the effects
artists at ILM came up with some
ingenious alternatives matte glass
paintings were painstakingly created by
hands and then added to scenes later but
a different technique was needed to
bring the movies many spaceships to life
former ILM frontman John Dykstra told
den of geek back in the days of Star
Wars we kind of walked into an empty
warehouse and set on the floor and went
how are we going to do this
the producers Gary Kurtz of Fox and
George Lucas took an incredible risk by
listening to what myself and my
collaborators had to say with regard to
how to do this because we were inventing
this stuff from scratch when it came to
Han Solo's Millennium Falcon Dykstra
decided to create a model and film it in
front of a blue screen using an early
computer-controlled camera which allowed
his team to add all of the outerspace
details in Post The Empire Strikes Back
Dykstra and his team won an Oscar for
the revolutionary work on Star Wars but
Lucas chose not to bring Dykstra along
when he moved his base of operations to
San Francisco it was here that ILM got
to work on the next movie but despite
the success of the first film budget
restraints were still a problem when it
came to making the Empire Strikes Back
as VFX supervisor Richard Edlund later
pointed out computer graphics were
extremely expensive very slow and the
resolution was always a problem
luckily for Edlund and Lucas the team
they'd assembled proved more than
capable of delivering results within
their me
the film's cinematographer mark Virgo
compared this era in cinematic history
to the lunar program referring to the
period as an amazing cooperative of
artists imagination optics engineering
and home-brewed software Return of the
Jedi
by the time 1983 s Return of the Jedi
went into production the ILM crew had
found their groove Master of Puppets
Phil Tippett was brought in to head up a
creature shop that ultimately created
the Ewoks and the rest of the effects
work was divided between Richard Edlund
Ken Ralston and Dennis Muren among the
jobs that fell to Mirren was the speeder
bike chase one of the hardest sequences
in the film with 100 total effect shots
Mir and explained because the bikes were
going to be blue screened the
backgrounds didn't require that many
different shots to do because we could
use them over and over again I got the
idea to do it with a Steadicam
I called Garrett Brown up who invented
it and he flew out from back east and we
did a test out in Samuel Taylor Park out
here with him just walking along with
the camera shooting one frame a second
and the thing worked Muller and Browne
spent several days in the woods
just filming trees from different angles
then matched the footage up when they
went back to the studio to film the
actors in front of the blue screens the
Phantom Menace George Lucas's
long-awaited return to the Star Wars
universe didn't fail financially but it
did let down a number of fans who were
quick to turn on new CGI character Jar
Jar Binks
despite the overwhelmingly negative
reaction to the character I'm at best
the man who played the Gungan is proud
of the fact that he broke new ground
with Jar Jar he explained one of the
biggest reasons I took it was because of
the challenge it hadn't been done before
there was no Andy Serkis and Gollum no
Navi from Avatar I was working with
George to pioneer this new character
form of acting and storytelling unlike
best the actor who played Darth Maul
only has fond memories of the fans of
menace his first experience on a movie
set martial artist and actor ray park
was initially only brought in to film
some test footage but Lucas liked his
work so much that he decided to cast him
as the Sith Lord park's primary
Fighting's
is wushu but he also practiced
gymnastics and ballet in preparation for
his big fight scene with obi-wan Kenobi
and qui-gon jinn once the choreography
was worked out the scene was filmed in
front of a custom blue set and handed
off to ILM just one of the many
sequences they were required to complete
Attack of the Clones
the ongoing advances in CGI meant that
Lucas could set stories in parts of his
galaxy that were previously inaccessible
which he took full advantage of an
attack of the clones
he explained that was the fun part of
writing the project I wasn't limited
whatever my imagination could come up
with I would just put down on the page
and say we'll worry about this later
animation director Rob Coleman was
initially under the impression that some
of the cityscapes and backgrounds Lucas
required for Episode two were going to
have some practical elements but he soon
learned this wasn't the case of the
2,000 effect shots and attack of the
clones around half include completely
computer-generated characters a team of
60 animators worked alongside 340 ILM
artists and technicians to render some
of the most well known Star Wars phases
in CGI including a certain little green
Jedi Master Rob Coleman explained the
biggest technical challenge for me was
animating Yoda that was due to Frank Oz
having created that character in the
Empire Strikes Back as a puppet
this time Yoda is much more active and
prominent he actually runs and has a
lightsaber battle
Yodas duel with Count Dooku was one of
the film's big visual effects set pieces
but it required some human input from
Christopher Lee who was one of the many
cast members forced to work with blue
screens for long periods of time Revenge
of the Sith according to Ian McDermott
who played sheev Palpatine the use of
green screen was really ramped up for
the third and final film in the Lucas
prequel trilogy which had the most
effect shots yet he told The Telegraph
so much of the filming took place in
front of a green screen I used to feel
great sympathy for you and in Hayden
because they had so much fighting to do
and quite often had to fight imagined
enemies
George often hadn't decided on the
details of the film so you and Hayden
didn't know if they were filming an
ironic moment or whether they were about
to
episode three also introduced us to
General Grievous the lightsaber wielding
cyborg who held the title of supreme
commander of the droid army during the
Clone Wars upon receiving the design for
the character animation director Rob
Coleman new ILM were going to have a
tough job breathing life into this one
he explained since his movement was so
restricted we decided to have him talk
with his hands because although there is
a grill pattern where his mouth should
be there are no articulating bits for
his mouth no lip sync or facial
expressions no brow to move no
indication of what he is feeling or
thinking grievous wasn't the only
villain without eyebrows in this movie
it's an episode 3 that we get to see
Anakin Skywalker become Darth Vader
after he's badly burned in a battle with
obi-wan a scene which had its own
effects challenges Hayden Christensen
wasn't originally going to be the person
in the iconic suit but in the end he
convinced Lucas to let him play the part
I begged them clean it and they were
nice enough to build the Darth Vader so
to actually fit me
the force awakens after working with JJ
Abrams on his Star Trek reboot visual
effects supervisor Roger Guyot joined
the director going into the force
awakens and the Paris partnership proved
as fruitful as ever episode 7 made over
two billion dollars globally while Guyot
and his team were nominated for an
Academy Award for their work much of
which incorporated practical effects in
particular real models were often used
for the little bb-8 droid guyot told our
two BFFs
from the beginning we knew we wanted
bb-8 to be as practical as possible so
that the actors could interact with him
and of course JJ could direct him on set
removing the puppeteers from shots later
on proved tricky but guyot had nothing
but praise for them despite all the
effort that went into making bb-8 real
there were still a number of scenes in
which the character had to be rendered
digitally out of necessity around a
third of all shots in fact obviously
some of the characters couldn't just be
done physically and and those occasions
judge I was more than happy to push the
digital technology of fully digital
actors for all the practical work guyot
estimates that the force awakens
contains around 2,100 effect shots
robe one a Star Wars story the first
Star Wars spin-off went in a new
direction in terms of both narrative and
style and most critics were impressed
with the result
one of the major talking points was the
digital resurrection of Peter Cushing as
grand moff tarkin whose character was
portrayed by guy Henry VIII emotion
capture VFX Supervisor John Knoll was
able to track down a cast of Cushing
Space made for the 1984 movie top secret
which gave them a huge head start when
it came to recreating the late actor's
likeness the process took a whopping 18
months to complete and was done with the
permission of cushing's estate of course
Tarkin wasn't the only CG character in
row 1 to create the droid k2s oh the
filmmakers fitted alan tudyk with a
motion capture suit and then digitally
added the robot's body later to get to
dicks face at the appropriate level for
the towering robot they took two
different approaches in some scenes
Dudek Wars stilts while he interacted
with the other actors
if the shot was too dangerous to you
stilts he wore a backpack with a paper
cutout of K two's head positioned
several feet above his own now that's
dedication
there's no way to Madinah the last Jedi
JJ Abrams spoke at length about using as
many practical effects as possible in
the force awakens in order to recreate
the feeling of the original trilogy and
his successor Ryan Johnson adopted the
same attitude when he took the reins for
the last Jedi Neal Scanlan returned to
head up the creature shop and this time
they were tasked with creating a new
breed of animal called a vortex a fox
like inhabitants of the planet crate
Scanlon told Entertainment Weekly the
idea is that these wonderful sort of
feral creatures had lived on this planet
and had consumed the planet's surface
and as such had become crystalline to
get an idea of how such a creature might
move they fitted a small dog with a suit
adorned with drinking straws the next
step was creating an animatronic puppet
that the casts could interact with in
scenes but much like the bb-8 build it
wasn't possible to use it 100% of the
time static models complete with 25,000
individual crystals were built for the
benefit of the VFX
who were able to scan them and render
the creatures however Johnson wanted
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]